so there's been some super interesting
testimony this week about Reproductive
Rights and abortion and uh
care for pregnant women in the aftermath
of Roe v Wade being overturned by the
Supreme Court and the Republicans on
this this Congressional panel have been
just embarrassing themselves day after
day after day and today I want to look
specifically at a series of questions
from Republican Congressman Ralph Norman
who represents South Carolina's Fifth
District he completely humiliated
himself with these questions about
post-birth abortion abortion after birth
which quite literally just doesn't exist
it's not a thing when when a baby dies
after birth when it's not an abortion
we're talking about something completely
different and Renita Shannon who's a
democratic State Rep from Georgia and
others did the best they could to keep
up with these absurd questions and see
if you can
find the full list like some of them
will be obvious but see if you can
really find the full list of fallacious
claims by this guy you agree with him
fantasize well I think okay so first of
all do you agree with infanticide
already we're taught what what are you
talking about infanticide are we talking
about abortion here or are we talking
about murder when kids are out in the
world using inflammatory language to
basically describe a situation that does
not happen we don't have infanticide
happening doctors would not do that and
neither would folks who have carried
okay what a healthy child do you agree
if a healthy child is born that is that
woman's right to decide if it lives or
dies what I think is based on your
question you have a very low opinion of
pregnant people because if you think
anybody answer the question excuse me
answer the question I'm answering it
talking over Witnesses what I'm talking
to you is nobody would carry a pregnancy
and then decide on a Monday because they
are bored that they want to have an
abortion that's ridiculous and it's
inflammatory what you're saying you're
talking about families who are in tough
situations where folks have been excited
about carrying a pregnancy most of the
abortions that happen later in pregnancy
are really tragedies where it's really a
disappointment for everyone involved but
you agree with it I take it with all
those words uh you do agree with
basically murdering a child after
they're born Miss uh Miss grave now this
is supposed to be about abortion this
isn't about murdering children after
they're born it's it's quite literally a
completely different question could you
answer that would you just say yes or no
I have to say
congressman
how you just characterize the
representative statement is is extremely
inflammatory in the type of thing that
it's dangerous and what you guys have
been talking today about the threats
against crisis pregnancy centers which I
assume are are serious and yeah by the
way crisis pregnancy centers are places
that convince women not to get abortions
this is generally absurd now this guy is
an embarrassment to himself and to his
State and to his constituents there's no
doubt about it nobody supports abortion
after birth because there is no such
thing now all of the questions this
guy's asking are obviously bad faith
questions the questions are being asked
in order not to be answered and I do
think that the witnesses could have been
better prepared for how to answer them
like I get that they're bad faith
questions
they want you not to answer by making it
a bad faith question
so that then you look bad I believe the
best approach is answer it and then
explain that the question is absurd and
it's a frustrating thing all around to
watch because this guy is such an
embarrassment I mean it's so it's hard
to imagine a worst Faith line of
questioning on what is a very serious
issue but he should have been dunked on
for equating abortion with murder
nobody's really even they're talking
past each other in a certain sense it's
not an abortion because birth happened
it's a mind-numbingly stupid question
but they should be able to say no we're
not for that and that has nothing to do
with decisions very difficult decisions
that relatively few families have to
make in the third trimester they they
are two completely different things they
continue to stretch this
cartoonification of abortion into well
is it okay to kill a child one month
after they're born what about six months
well what about just deciding at two
years old you're not liking this
parenthood thing see it they the
question can be answered Congressman of
course I'm not for infanticide and what
we're talking about here are
um there's it's not a there's not a
pediatrician involved there's an OB GYN
because what we're talking about here is
a pregnancy it's still a pregnancy at
seven months eight months Etc and it's
exceedingly rare nobody goes in uh a
week before their due date and says you
know what
I want to get an abortion every OB GYN
who has testified over the last two
weeks on that says it never happens and
we wouldn't do it now could you find
someone that would say sure I'll do it
probably you could find someone doesn't
mean it's even something that's
happening uh but the the the the
questions are designed for you to feel
like you can't answer them so that you
don't so that Norman can go and say
since you're not answering I must assume
you're okay with infanticide the entire
thing is mind-numbingly stupid they
could have been better prepared he's
still embarrassing he still should be
embarrassed uh but they could have been
better prepared I never have time to
read all of the non-fiction books that I
want to read our sponsor blinkist has
solved the problem for me in a way
because blinkist takes thousands of the
best and newest non-fiction books
extracts the key takeaways and then you
can either read or listen to them in 15
minutes I read all the time I love of
narrative nonfiction I read economics I
read all these different things as I
said before I would love to have time to
read more history I just don't right now
especially with a newborn you should see
what's going on in the middle of the
night but uh with blinkist I was able to
read in fact I listened to a 15-minute
audio version of Putin's people by
Catherine Belton with what's going on in
Ukraine and Russia I just wanted more
history how did in fact the book is
called how the KGB took back Russia and
then took on the west I wanted to learn
how did this adversarial situation
develop what is the history of the Putin
KGB coming to power Etc I did not have
time to read that book in full but in
just 15 minutes with blinkist I was able
to get all of the uh key points which
now I can use when I am talking about
Ukraine and Russia and have more context
blankest has condensed over 5 000
non-fiction books in 27 categories try
blinkist free for seven days and get 25
off a subscription at blinkist.com
Pacman the link is down below